happy International Women's Day I
noticed she got applause for that so I'm
totally that was applause bait right
there so thank you hi my name is Susan
Lee and I am the head of people at Warby
Parker I am a woman so I'm a woman I'm
over 40 I am a person of color
I am korean-american I'm a feminist I'm
a Democrat I am a Southern Californian I
am an unapologetic year-round rose a
drinker
I am a snowboarder and I'm waiting for
the plus I'm a romance novelist growing
up labels were something that we're not
a good sign for me it basically meant
limitations to the opportunities I have
for my life so I always thought about I
don't want to be labeled I don't want
people to make assumptions about me I
don't want them to take away what I'm
working hard for when my parents
emigrated from Korea my dad came here
and he registered and his first thought
was he was going to register as Charles
Lee le IgH because he did not want the
name to make it seem like he was any
different than anyone else
thankfully they didn't allow him to do
that because I loved my last name even
though there was like a million Susan
leaves if I go to Sephora there is like
last name I'm like no no email when I
started school I was learning English
and talking to my teachers and my
friends and when I came home my parents
only spoke Korean to me and I knew they
knew English they had broken English and
heavily accented but it wasn't till a
few years later that I realized they
never spoke English to me so I once
asked my dad I'm like dad I'd love to
practice your English why don't you ever
want to talk to me and he said I don't
want you to learn English with an accent
I don't want anyone to pick up the phone
and talk to you and assume that you're
any different than any other person I
grew
believing that I was American I very
rarely identified as Korean American
when I was there in third grade I wanted
to play a sport so we went to line and
it was I went in the line for Little
League baseball and when I got to the
front of the line they said actually
girls softball is in that field over
there and I pitched a fit I said I don't
want to play with the big ball I want to
play with a little ball with the boys
and I started screaming and my dad said
to them this doesn't say boys Little
League it just says Little League even
though you call that girls softball so
they allowed me to play it was the only
girl in Little League I wish I could say
I hit all the home runs and stuff but
that doesn't happen that's fine it's
totally fine I would take the twins
where we can get him so when I was ready
to graduate and I was about to go to
college they said what do you want to
study what do you want to be and I'm
like well what are my options and
they're like well if you want to be
successful you have to be a doctor a
lawyer an engineer or a businesswoman
and I was like that's all my options
okay I'll be a doctor so for five years
I studied biochem almost flunking out
probably every year knowing there was no
way that I was going to go to med school
and and it was really because I didn't
feel like I had options I didn't know
about HR I didn't know about marketing I
didn't know about supply chain or PR or
any other opportunity out there for me
when I graduated I took a job as an
administrative assistant when they gave
me the phone list it wasn't off abetik
oh it was listed by your hierarchy and I
was all the way at the bottom and I'm
like I don't want to be at the bottom of
this list so anytime an opportunity came
up I'd say I'll do it I'll change the
lightbulbs I'll fix the printer I will
fix the network that works the printer
and when they notice that I was willing
to do anything they sent me to school
and I became a network engineer network
engineer I know now I'm an HR story for
another time the next two acts but
eventually in 1999 and I'm thinking most
of you weren't even born then but in
1999 there was a time in the world where
Microsoft ruled this world and came this
phenomenon called y2k where Microsoft
thought that because their calendaring
and their system wasn't able to flip to
the year two
and they're worried that all the systems
were gonna like break so my company sent
a bunch of us to third-world countries
to look at their network infrastructure
so I was sent to Kazakhstan this was
before Borat I may I put Kazakhstan the
map not Bora so I went to Kazakhstan and
they told me when I was there you have
to be very aware of two things you're a
woman and you're an American and this
was before 9/11 so it wasn't that they
had bad feelings towards America it was
actually as a woman in American I was at
highest risk to be kidnapped to be
become a bride a blushing bride and
taking bringing my husband back to
America so all of my life I shunned
labels I just like F that I don't
believe in any of this I'm gonna break
these labels they don't belong to me I
don't identify this way the one label or
mantra that I live by is put your head
down work hard don't cause any trouble
someone will notice and you'll climb
your way up that's basically how my
parents raised me don't cause any
trouble put your head down work hard
someone's gonna notice and it's exactly
how I got to where I am today
then November 2016 happened and I won't
make this political but I already told
you whether what I vote but Donald Trump
was elected president and it was a new
administration in the White House and
suddenly all of these things that I took
for granted what I look like my gender
my age my pay rate were in jeopardy I
could be a target for any number of
discrimination or the way that people
saw me and I realized that because I
never labeled myself I didn't know what
I was gonna stand for what I was willing
to fight for what I was gonna March for
I just never thought about that stuff i
shun labels so only feminists march in
the women's March or you know it's like
only LGBTQ people go to Pride and like I
just didn't think that any of that was
for me and what's crazy is I've you know
told him over 40 that this realization
that I
didn't know myself happen only two years
ago so I told mentioned that I'm a
romance novelist I'm actually started as
a romance reader and at Warby Parker
were big readers and we talk about books
all the time and in my interview with
our CEO he said hey what are you reading
and it's a classic interview question
for us
if you're ever interviewing remember
that one be prepared and I thought I
need to say something really smart so
think of a leadership book a nonfiction
book what is it what is it and my mind
was blank and I and I thought you know
what
I gotta come clean because if he hires
me in two weeks later he says he had
that book turned out I'd be like oh good
so I came clean I told him I'm reading
this book it's uh it's called sweet
dreams by Kristen Ashley and basically
it's about this guy who's a bartender
and he's on a motorcycle club and
there's this woman who's down and out
and she finds her way to this small town
and they fall in love I remember to this
day the look of horror on his face he
was like and anyone who knows him he
gets really uncomfortable very easily
and it was just just comfort in horror
and he gave this laugh and then he said
oh well that was unexpected but thank
you for your honesty but what's
important that I always put out there
the reason why I read romance is I deal
with real-life situation all day long
that's what I do I deal with people all
day I get to see the best in people and
I also hear the worst about life and
what people are going through so when I
come home I want to get lost in that
fantasy or fairy tale of the billionaire
who falls in love with his personal
trainer or the over-40 girl single who
lives in Soho find some anniversaries
but and they live happily ever after the
end
but what I came to realize that I've
been reading romance and loving all of
these stories again when I started to
recognize Who I am I noticed I don't see
myself in these stories very rarely do I
see the Korean girl not as fit as she
should be
look who is a little bit older I don't
see that
so I set out to change something and
decide to start writing them myself so I
write what we call them thank you cannot
read it so you don't know if they're any
good but I write what we call own voices
hashtag own voices romance and almost
always it's a Korean American
protagonist someone successful and
someone who you know finds their happily
ever after and now I know that people
will get to see that but if I never
identified or labeled myself a Korean
American it wouldn't have mattered if
these books were out there or not so
currently I'm writing a young adult
romance it's about a Korean American
teenager she is bullied mercilessly for
having small eyes a flat nose for her
clothes smelling like fish
her parents having broken English but
when she turned 16 all of her bullying
turns into superpowers so her small eyes
can see miles away and her flat nose can
smell evil and at the end of the day she
saves the world and she wins the captain
of the football team so predictable but
and I love that I love that I get to
tell these kinds of stories where people
like me get to be the hero the heroine I
can legitimately in all honesty say that
this is the happiest I've ever been in
my entire life and the reason I think
this is true is because I absolutely
Know Who I am now
if you asked me two or three years ago
who are you I would have given you an
answer that at least 50 other people in
this room would have could have also
identified and said yes I can say oh I'm
a generally happy person I'm like you
know I try to be positive
bla bla bla and I mean I like long walks
on the beach it's like things that other
people could say but if you take the
whole of all the labels that I put out
and introduce myself as I know that is
distinctly me that is exactly who I am
and you know if there is my long-lost
twin out there with all those same
things
talk to me later let's drink some wine
but I believe this is just me and that
makes me super super excited because
number one I know what I'm willing to
fight for I know what I stand for I know
what I
going to draw a line in the sand about I
know what my ride-or-die is gonna be and
it's also just the guideposts on how I
want to live and how I want to keep
moving forward the stories that I want
to tell so I am super excited at the end
of this to meet you guys and I'd love to
hear some of your labels I'd love to
hear what identifies you your
identifiers because ultimately I think
that brings a lot of connection and it
makes you uniquely thank you
[Applause]